[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
willkommen zurück zu Tatort Deutschland
dem täglichen True Crime Podcast von
Bild mein Name ist Toni Heyer und mit
mir ist mein lieber Kollege Mirko
Kasimir hallo Mirko hallo grüß Dich Toni
unsere heutige Geschichte handelt von
einem Mann der als der schlimmste
Serienmörder Großbritanniens gilt
215 Maude sind heute bestätigt weitere
45 werden vermutet verurteilt wurde er
für 15 alles begann am
21.08.1974 im Nordwesten Englands nicht
weit von Manchester in einer kleinen
Stadt namens
also Leute ich muss das jetzt hier mal
kurz aufklären wenn ihr das schriftlich
sehen würdet das wird geschrieben wie im
Deutschen Tod und Morden also für
Engländer klingt dieser Name natürlich
nicht so finster wie für uns hat auch
eine ganz andere harmlose Bedeutung er
geht nämlich auf den Personennamen toter
zurück aber naja also wenn man über
einen Massenmörder berichtet und über so
einen Namen in der Recherche stolpert
dann kann man nicht anders das fällt
einfach auf also august 1974 Milko
die Lane ausworld hat leichte Schmerzen
in der Seite sicher nicht Ernstes denkt
sie aber ein Arztbesuch kann trotzdem
nicht schaden
da geht sie noch davon aus dass sie
nachmittags wieder auf Arbeit sein wird
sie kennt den Arzt noch nicht den Sie an
diesem Tag aufsucht er ist noch sehr
jung und nur ein paar Jahre älter als
sie und dabei ist sie selbst erst 25
trotzdem vertraut sie ihm sofort dr
Harold Shipman ist ein freundlicher Mann
mit großer Brille und Bart er setzt sich
neben sie statt wie andere Ärzte hinter
seinem großen Schreibtisch zu Drohnen
doch leider hat er schlechte Nachrichten
vielleicht sind es Nierensteine erklärt
heute wird es also nichts mehr mit der
Arbeit er verschreibt dir ein starkes
Schmerzmittel und schickt sie nach Hause
nach seiner Schicht in der Klinik wird
er einen Hausbesuch bei ihr machen und
einen Bluttest durchführen wie
versprochen steht der abends vor ihrer
Tür es dauert nicht lange verspricht er
meine Frau und mein Sohn warten draußen
im Auto nur ein kleiner bisschen Blut
dann bin ich wieder weg
die Nadel fährt in ihren Arm dann dreht
sich alles dann wird es schwarz um sie
herum
als Elaine wieder zu sich kommt liegt
sie auf dem Boden der Doktor und zwei
Rettungssanitäter beugen sich über sie
später erfährt sie was passiert ist sie
hatte einen Kreislauf Zusammenbruch was
für ein glücklicher Zufall dass dr
Schippmann gerade bei ihr war er hat sie
mit Herzdruckmassage und Mund zu Mund
Beatmung gerettet
die Lane kommt mit dem Schrecken
angeknacksten Rippen und einer kleinen
Verletzung an der Lippe davon
das Krankenhauspersonal behandelt sie
abfällig denn hier geht man davon aus
dass sie sich absichtlich eine Überdosis
Schmerzmittel verabreicht hat doch dr
Schippmann steht ja bei es habe sich
nicht um eine Überdosis sondern um eine
allergische Reaktion auf das Mittel
gehandelt eine Woche später lädt er
Elaine und ihren Mann zum Dinner ein er
hat sogar ein Geschenk für sie ein
notfallarmband auf dem ihre Allergie
gegen das Schmerzmittel vermerkt ist
25 Jahre ist sie voller Dankbarkeit für
den Arzt der ihr das Leben gerettet und
sich so rührend um sie gekümmert hat ja
bis 1999 da liest sie in der Zeitung von
einem Prozess gegen den Arzt Dr Harald
Chapman genannt dr Tod
Elaine Oswald ist vermutlich das erste
Opfer des Serienmörders sie hat nicht
überlebt weil Dr Schippmann zur Stelle
war sie hat überlebt obwohl dr
Schippmann zur Stelle war mehr als 200
Menschen hatten weniger Glück als sie
[Musik]
wird 1946 in Nottingham geboren er ist
ein guter Schüler und exzellente
Rugby-Spieler als er 17 ist nimmt sein
Leben eine tragische Wendung bei seiner
Mutter wird lungenkrebsdiagnostiziert
Harald der ihr sehr nahe steht
beobachtet ihr sterben und erlebt wie
die Ärzte ihr im Endstadium Morphin
spritzen um ihre Schmerzen zu lindern er
ist erschüttert und inspiriert
Shipman beginnt ein Medizinstudium und
heiratet
1970 schließte das Studium ab er beginnt
als Assistenzarzt auf einer
Krankenstation doch schon 1974 nimmt er
eine Stelle als Allgemeinmediziner in
Torten an wo er Elaine Oswald trifft und
höchstwahrscheinlich versucht sie mit
einer Überdosis Schmerzmittel zu
ermorden dr Tod hat seine Methode
gefunden aber dieser erste Mordversuch
macht ihm eines klar eine 25-jährige die
plötzlich zusammenbricht und beinahe
stirbt das Weg zu viel Aufmerksamkeit
doch bald findet er die perfekten Opfer
das nächste Opfer ist IVA Lions sie
stirbt im März 1975 und todmüttern an
einer Überdosis Schmerzmittel am Abend
vor ihrem 75 geburtstag
von jetzt an konzentriert er sich auf
alte oft einsame Menschen deren Tod
niemand groß verwundert von 1975 bis
1999 tötet er mindestens 215 Menschen
171 Frauen und 44 Männer die älteste ist
93 der jüngste 41 Jahre alt viele von
ihnen sterben zu Hause während eines
Hausbesuches des netten dr Schippmann
der Tod kommt oft überraschend für die
Angehörigen ein Tag zuvor schien es dem
Opfer noch gut zu gehen aber okay sie
sind alt haben vielleicht
Vorerkrankungen sowas passiert halt aber
wie gut dass der freundliche Arzt zur
Stelle war um Ihnen in ihren letzten
Minuten beizustehen in vielen
Totenschein steht als Ursache einfach
nur Alter dr Schippmann füllt sie meist
allein aus
im Nachhinein betrachtet ist es eine
völlig offensichtliche Häufung von
scheinbaren Zufällen das ein Patient
ausgerechnet während eines Hausbesuchs
stirbt kommt vor aber sehr sehr selten
bei dr harrid Shipman passierte es
dauernd doch lange Zeit schöpft niemand
Verdacht einige wundern sich zwar über
dem plötzlichen Tod der Mutter oder
Großmutter doch sie alle akzeptieren
schließlich die Erklärungen des Arztes
er ist ja auch so verdammt freundlich
und aufopferungsvoll man muss ihm
einfach vertrauen der mörderische Arzt
hätte viel früher gestoppt werden können
man hätte keinen genialen Profiler oder
super Detektiv dafür gebraucht sondern
nur ein bisschen Statistik eine stark
erhöhte Sterberate unter shipments
Patienten und vor allem die vielen
Todesfälle in seiner Anwesenheit hätten
alle Alarmglocken schrillen lassen
müssen wenn jemand hier mal eine
einfache Statistik erhoben hätte ja
Statistik klingt jetzt erstmal öde was
aber manchmal ist ein bisschen Mathe
wichtiger als mit hochgeklappten
Mantelkragen und gezückter Pistole Türen
einzutreten oder im regnerischen Nächten
Verdächtige zu beschatten bei diesem
Fall aber achtet leider niemand auf
Zahlen und auch die Polizei kommt nicht
auf den Plan denn schließlich hat
niemand einen Mord gemeldet trotzdem
kommt jemand dem todesarzt auf die
Schliche ein Taxifahrer wird ein
misstrauisch John Schaum wohnt in der
Kleinstadt Haid in der heroldship man
seit 1993 eine Praxis für
Allgemeinmedizin betreibt zu John
schaust besten Kunden gehören viele
ältere Menschen die er regelmäßig zu
Arzt besuchen oder zu geplanten
Operationen ins Krankenhaus fährt in
einer öffentlichen Anhörung zu
Untersuchung der chipman-morde im Jahr
2003 erzählt er die Patienten wurden
meine Freunde dann riefen mich Verwandte
an und sagten holen sie meine Mutter
nicht ab sie ist tot
ich fing an mir Gedanken zu machen ich
fragte wer Ihr Arzt sei ja und die
Antwort war fast immer dr Harald chipman
spätestens 1995 beginnt sich Taxifahrer
short zu wundern aber er zögert seinen
Verdacht zu melden er zögert drei Jahre
lang drei Jahre in denen Harald chipman
20 Menschen tötet und für deren Tod sich
John Show eine Mitschuld gibt er erklärt
es so die Tatsache dass shipment eine so
angesehene Persönlichkeit in der
Gemeinde war machte es umso schwieriger
meine Bedenken öffentlich zu äußern sie
waren so fantastisch dass ich nicht
begreifen konnte was mein Verstand mir
sagte
ich hatte genauso viel Angst davor Recht
zu haben wie auch Unrecht zu haben
1998 meldet er sein Verdacht endlich der
Polizei inzwischen ist auch eine
Kollegin shipments die Ärztin Linda
Reynolds misstrauisch geworden sie
wundert sich über die große Anzahl von
einäscherungsformularen
ältere Frauen die chipman gegenzeichnen
lässt die Polizei untersucht die
Angelegenheit stellt die Ermittlungen
jedoch bald wieder ein es könnten keine
ausreichenden Beweise für eine Anklage
gefunden werden heißt es ja da hat man
wohl nicht allzu genau gesucht
spätestens jetzt hätte man sich die
Statistiken ansehen müssen dann wären
die hohe Sterberate und die absurde
Häufung von Todesfällen in seiner
Anwesenheit aufgefallen und der Spuk
wäre ganz schnell vorbei gewesen so
sterben nach Abschluss der Ermittlungen
drei weitere Menschen sein letztes Opfer
ist die 81-Jährige Caroline grandi eine
ehemalige Bürgermeisterin
Shipman ermordet sie am 24 Juni auf dem
Totenschein steht als Tor des Ursache
wie so oft fortgeschrittenes Alter doch
diesmal ist etwas anders einen Tag vor
Catherine Grande ist tot geht ein
Testament beim Notar ein die alte Dame
vermachterin ihr ganzes Vermögen fast
400.000 Pfund Ihrem Arzt dem guten dr
Schippmann Kinder und Enkelkinder gehen
leer aus ihr ahnt schon da ist etwas
mächtig faul und schnell erweist sich
das Testament als Fälschung Mirko
vielleicht müssen wir kurz über das
Motiv reden warum hat chipman diese
Menschen umgebracht das mit dem
Testament klingt ja nach einem
klassischen Fall von Mord aus hab hier
ja das scheint ziemlich offensichtlich
und das unterscheidet den Fall Catherine
grandi von shipments anderen Morgen denn
zuvor hat er nicht getötet um sich zu
bereichern er hat getötet um zu töten
es gab in den letzten Jahren einige
Fälle von mörderischen Ärzten oder
Krankenpflegern oft ist eine
fehlgeleitete Menschenfreundlichkeit des
Mordmotiv klingt paradox ich weiß Ärzte
die einen unheilbar kranken Patienten
von seinen Leiden erlösen wollen so
sehen Sie es zumindest und die mit der
Zeit immer selbst herrlicher werden sich
zu Herren überleben und Tod aufschwingen
selbst entscheiden wer leben darf und
wer erlöst werden muss und dann gibt es
die Fälle in denen ein Arzt oder
Krankenpfleger Patienten fast umbringt
um sie dann spektakulär zu retten und
als Held darzustehen auch wenn das heißt
dass sie einige davon nicht mehr retten
können genauso einen Fall einen sehr
berühmten aus Deutschland werden wir
demnächst hier besprechen das Leben von
Menschen als ego-booster das ist so
traurig und Entschuldigung ekelhaft
das auch ein bisschen wie die
Geschichten von Feuerwehrmännern die zu
Brandstiftern werden um dann ihr eigenes
Feuer zu löschen aber keine Sorge sowas
gibt es zwar doch normalerweise ist es
doch die weggeworfene Kippe oder der
Kurzschluss der für ein Brand sorgt und
das gleiche gilt für die Ärzteschaft nur
um das vorsichtshalber noch mal
klarzustellen Fälle wie der von Harold
Chapman sind eine totale Ausnahme und er
hätte heutzutage auch nicht mehr ein so
leichtes Spiel solche spektakulären
Fälle haben natürlich die Öffentlichkeit
und die Behörden alarmiert und
sensibilisiert eine todesstatistik wie
die von Harald Schiffmann würde heute
wesentlich früher auffallen okay shit
man wollte also wieder den Helden
spielen noch ungefragte Sterbehilfe
leisten um Geld ging es ihm auch nicht
also zumindest bis zu seinem letzten
Opfer aber wie scheint ging es ihm
wirklich nur um das Töten an sich und
auf verdrehte Weise hängt das wohl alles
mit dem Kre Tod seiner Mutter und den
Schmerzmitteln die er verabreicht wurden
zusammen das werden wir nie genauer
fahren auch nicht warum er das Testament
fälschte wollte er vielleicht erwischt
werden hoffte er darauf mit dem Geld
Untertauchen zu können es muss ihm klar
geworden sein dass man ihm auf der Spur
war die Obduktion der Leiche von
Catherine grandi ergab als Todesursache
übrigens eine Überdosis Diamorphin
besser bekannt als Heroin in
Großbritannien wird das Opioid bis heute
in der Schmerztherapie eingesetzt
Shipman hat sich über die Jahre einen
Vorrat zugelegt indem er es bei
Krebspatienten im Endstadium abzweigte
dies eigentlich dringend brauchten nur
um dann damit wiederum alte aber gesunde
Menschen umzubringen irre im Januar 2000
steht mein vor Gericht er streitet alle
Vorwürfe ab und gibt keine Auskunft zu
Motiven
nach sechs Tagen wird shipment wegen
15-fachen Mordes und Fälschung eines
Testaments zu 15 mal lebenslang
verurteilt auf weitere Verfahren
verzichtet man wegen des zu erwartenden
presserunges und weil man aus
offensichtlichen Gründen die Strafe
sowieso nicht weiter hätte verschärfen
können ja klar also mit 200 Mal
lebenslangen sitzt du am Ende genauso
lang wie mit 15 mal also bis zum Tod
aber für die Angehörigen wäre es
vielleicht trotzdem sehr sehr wichtig
gewesen dann offizielles Urteil zu
bekommen
vier Jahre nach der Verurteilung nimmt
sich Dr Harold Shipman im Gefängnis das
Leben dr Tod ist tot
[Musik]
und wir sind für heute am Ende angelangt
die Geschichte von Dr Tod haben wir
unter anderem mit Beiträgen aus The
Guardian New Scientist und auf der
Webseite der BBC erzählt sowie anhand
einer Episode des großartigen
englischsprachigen Podcasts kostenary
Tales with time hafert danke euch fürs
Zuhören bleibt uns treu empfiehlt uns
weiter wenn euch gefällt was wir hier
machen und bewertet ihn doch gerne auch
bei Apple Podcast Spotify oder wo immer
ihr uns auch zuhört Skript und
Postproduktion dieser Ausgabe Wake world
Studios München Schnitt Toni Heyer
Redaktion Stefan danke für heute und bis
zum nächsten mal eure Toni